اجتماع جديد لطاوله السداسيه اكبر ائتلاف
معارض في تركيا قاده سته احزاب معارضه
يجتمعون للمره ال 11
تحضيرا للانتخابات القادمه
بيان المعارضه بعد الاجتماع اكد ان ترشح
اردوغان لمنصب الرئيس للمره الثالثه مخالف
للدستور ما لم يحظى بموافقه البرلمان رغم
تاكيد مؤيد الائتلاف الحاكم ان احزاب
المعارضه تنشغل بقضايا كشرعيه انتخاب
اردوغان والمرحله الانتقاليه والتحول الى
النظام البرلماني لعجزها عن اختيار مرشح
مشترك ترا اوساط المعارضه انا الطاوله
السداسيه انما تعمل على تحديد معايير
واضحه ومحدده للرئيس مع صلاحيات تعزز
التجربه الديمقراطيه دون وجود خلاف حول
شخصيه اردوغان
المساعده طول السداسيه في حارس يكون لهم
مرشح سيكون هناك امور عديده للنقاش منها
مرشح الرئاسه ونائبه وكيف ستدار هذه
الفتره يعني كيف ستشكل التحالفات للاحزاب
او وضعها بعد الانتخابات يجب ان تتوضح تلك
الامور
المرشح المشترك للمعارضه هو الملف
والخلافي الابرز ولا توافق حتى الان على
شخصيه مرشح لكن البيان اشار الى انهم
توصلوا الى اتفاق حول خطه العمل في
المرحله الانتقاليه قبل التحول الى النظام
البرلماني اذا فازت المعارضه بالانتخابات
هذا الذي يقوم به بعد هذه الخطوه سيقومون
بالتحضير للنظام البرلماني وبعدها يمكن
حينها اختيار المرشح للرئاسه ونائب الرئيس
ووافقه مصادره مطلعه فان خيارات عده
يناقشها قاده الاحزاب السته حاليا من
بينها ان يكون للرئيس خمسه نواب هم بقيه
قاده الاحزاب في الطاوله السداسيه وطرح
اخر يقترح ان يكون الرئيس من حزب الشعب
ونائبه من حزب الخير وبقيه الاحزاب يكون
لها وزارات في الحكومه اسابيعه قليله فقط
للانتخابات وقضيه مرشح المعارضه ما زالت
تشغل الشارع وفي رايك كثيرين ان تاخر
المعارضه اكثر او فشلها في اختيار مرشح
مشترك انما يصب في مصلحه حمله اردوغان
الانتخابيه لتماسك معسكر في مقابل عدم
الاتفاق في المعسكر الاخر زيدان زينجو
العربيه اسطنبول